house ago and bread my spirit of ha
welcome to one of the last episodes of
beyond 2 souls are you ready let's do it
alright
we came we came me gain happens they
didn't think about this seriously
oh sure
you can't even pull out that out find
something else but this get help
ah hurry Cole
oh yeah he was he was with a scotch
right he was gonna celebrate you bros
remember my guide who is riskier to you
he would never lend some neck if three
months leave on a guy from exotic island
no doubt guys bestest I don't see
anything how do i distract them yeah
I've got a couple of emails I need to
send you mind if I do that before we
crack the bottle no problem who says
that
that's me something weird about yeah
there's someone here guys you guys are
on my team right really you don't see
anything weird with that really really
really you're just gonna play off that
really
you keep entities in this lab it's good
god no you're all trapped behind the
containment field
iDEN yes
is that you iDEN yes this is a joke it's
not funny
ed why would I didn't beat you it's ma
what is it Iron Horse Jody downstairs
right on there to the whiteboard
now what write on the whiteboard lead us
to Jody items oh that's the way oh I am
just a moment
alright here we go this way right
nowhere I need to show him okay yeah
this way
and now you go yeah
yeah okay again good yeah this guy's you
don't have to be so slow
all right now why how we're gonna leave
him there
the elevator okay you think they after
all the year what is that it they
figured out a way to communicate its
floor - right I don't know which floor I
guess it doesn't matter okay those
[ __ ]
I never liked Ryan this much I bet it's
gonna save her
what is this garden leave it to me what
are they and here Cole Freeman I have a
level three authorization
he's with me mmm I'm sorry mr. Freeman
you do not have the correct
authorization for this level maybe you
could make an exception I just want to
show him sorry sir
this area is level four classified you
do not have the right credentials what
are we gonna do then there's gotta get
us past mining the scat of fax machine
instead telephone that's what innit
desk 42 hello
we distracted him yes of course
how do I make them try again though what
are these things
ah cool I think you made a mistake could
you check again please Cole Freeman Ryan
clean I'd be like ah just go away and
idiot room thank you
it's like alright alright take us to
Jodi let's find Jodi I actually you
don't know where she is
oh she's here okay this way this way
I think yes right now we're kind of wait
we're sorry you bring Colcord notice
okay here she's in here all right Jodi's
here
yes all right Joey
hey he's gonna deactivate the
containment field what why why would he
do that
yeah whoo
dubstep monsters always shake
oh really
are we yeah okay come on guys
shake whoa I find someone's gonna die I
know this because I know this this way
take the elevator at times like this but
Ella
it is knowledge
the spine seems nice
how the hell is it even possible
are you [ __ ] dick how much you [ __ ]
off
do McGrath
and needs is a son of a [ __ ] like you
yeah go let my wrists go Clayton after
you sir yeah now what do we do now what
I'm doing here
I don't see anything I got I guess
there's nothing I can do
sorry
it's not working
stop the condenser or reactivate the
fields that looks like a bike off
wait that's probably last week the
x-trail fun
what why
all right hurry we're out of Thomas
ryang what is what are you doing
it's a portable containment field you
should've taken me long enough to reach
the condenser and trigger the manual
self-destruct right why don't die girl
she's ripped it's a long shot
what's the best idea when you're talking
crazy Cole we need to get out of here
that the military put it down a [ __ ]
mess no we need to do it
Jodi no holes right it's our only chance
of course right of course although
there's only three belts yeah I figured
I died a hero
this is pretty cool I don't know what's
going on but I like it
the center of the dome no one's ever
been before so there's no telling what
we'll find down there how much time do
we have I come back to Bayliss up just
the system was designed to be activated
remotely the explosion would be
practically instantaneous we're not
coming back oh yeah oh no hmm
we're coming back
we're gonna fight them I hope so
the condensers on the other side of that
door
we've got company they haven't seen us
yet it's our only chance
Jesus I hope you're right
for our little trip into the fo world
might come to a sticky end
recover us the final chance
yeah
joke don't get too close to them thanks
for the tip I have really appreciated
I know I'm supposed to click now oh [ __ ]
according to how she moves but that
looked like a duck to me and I press
down works
and we're fine
where's Ryan
Oh sh I know we're saving it now give a
[ __ ]
come on Cole
nobody he's right come on Joey
your hand
gosh seconds
Africa
we got to move on
I don't like what this is going brahs
I don't know what I feel about this
geez please don't play with my emotions
whoa
do
black holes sands
damn
what
this place is not nice
it's all the people
are we ever gonna arrive to it
damn it's like forever
set our mom
have you seen it
what
Oh No
Rion Rion I told you we ever arriving
it's so weird it sounds like we're not
getting closer
hello Mike
oh dude what are you doing
how about reason with it maybe it's
because they don't recognize you anymore
your anger has changed you
and so much
reason
that's impossible
you know it's the only way
come on
you're not gonna shoot her right
I missed you
like this do so much
you're the only one who can fix his
shoddy
not for me
Johnny thank you
damn that timeout
come on
let's finish this [ __ ]
what are we gonna do when we arrive to
it though
you're saying
they're not happy are they
why aren't they attacking Ryan my god
it's so much easier now that I
understand that I have to move the way
she
I always had to guess like what did they
mean Oh friendly night I thought that
was right I guess I will never
understand it
I prefer to everywhere you his [ __ ]
play than you know
Oh No
oh no I know what's gonna happen
Ryan give it to her give it to her
get out here for tape
panic
playing with my emotions beyond I don't
like it okay it's not cool
don't ask me healthy
we inject you with newel acid
exactly what we did it's too late
it's too late
you must have five to seven
I mean you
almost there
I know those two are
all the bad things that happen through
Jodi
and there were not a few of them I'm
sick and tired of their stories you're
really gonna get it
wait son what it's item that they took
away its minds me of the Fahrenheit
ending when he's sitting on this stomach
yes are they they identical because
our souls were bound together
why would you hate it you four years
but you are me
oh the explosion
what what is that I didn't do anything
their sign another world coming the wind
the Stars the universe
I didn't those I've loved forever
well I get to choose or well I thought I
miss click usually got a heart attack
being a virgin
growing away
some of the things I still have to do
what are we gonna do
I mean yeah we gotta choose why
Shay
he didn't die huh thought for sure I am
die
we're live
will item you gun
yeah I didn't we'll be gone
I didn't
baby
Jody we made it
what about Biden
so that's how it looks like on the
inside [ __ ]
all right for us I'm really sorry I'm
gonna upload the next part as soon as I
can
if we came this far we're gonna finish
it together let me like him enjoyed
watching hit subscribe home birth day
I'll see ya
stairs rest love you right there